so there's so much stuff going on with
Benghazi it's hard to kind of get all
the facts in place but basically on last
September 11th our embassy in Libya was
attacked and then over the next couple
days the administration sort of rolled
out these talking points that Susan Rice
was going on all the talk shows and
saying that this was a spontaneous thing
having to do with that innocence of
Muslims YouTube video how am i doing so
far
okay and then no and then now it's come
out last week after a congressional
hearing that this was more of a
premeditated attack that they believe
Muslim extremists were involved and it
was terrorism okay so that's the take it
away so does it matter that was good you
have a few dead people this was a lot of
wonderful ambassador it's a horrible
shame and it's unfortunate but there was
a fabulous Huffington Post article last
week and I wish I remember the
gentleman's name and he said George
Bush's 15 Benghazi's and he listed the
15 embassy attacks under Bush's watch
where many people were killed and nobody
made this kind of hay out of it because
they weren't desperate for something to
hang their campaigns on to these people
should be ashamed of themselves wasting
the time they are supposed to be
advocating for their constituents
wasting their day at work on this crap
and these are the same people who voted
for cuts that cut back on security and
military personnel and I think that
everyone knows at this point that
Republicans and conservative pundits on
like Fox News are using this to their
political advantage which makes it such
a despicable issue but at the same time
I do think that there are people out
there that are genuine and their
concerns and they're worried about the
way that the situation was handled so
there were a number of violent attacks
in the area prior to you know the attack
on the US consulate in Benghazi and so
there was a failure on the CIA's part
there and so that's a legitimate concern
first not the worst either and I think
what's bad
I'm a concern I don't think the Obama
administration handled it properly by
trying to use innocence of Muslims as a
scapegoat okay they should have admitted
that there was an issue and that they
were working to investigate it and
figure it out and make their the CIA
stronger when it comes to determining
other attacks
yeah wait let me just jump in there
protect why do you think they did that
so quickly because that's what Fox News
seems not for a moment that it was that
well well Fox News seems to be pushing
this idea or at least ng grant is push
they push in this matter in any actual
here's how you end things like this okay
here's what you do Hillary Clinton
should just come out and say oh yes I
wanted everyone to die yeah you're right
I wanted them to die I it worked out
perfectly what can they then say well
she sort of did that you know these guys
are not doing their job and they're just
you know it's total bait and switch for
governing leave this stuff to be let
this people rest in peace and do your
job yeah but do you think it matters
that they did roll out what now has
proven to sort of not be true at least
from the innovation like that pal
bringing fake drugs to the yeah the UN
right to say that was enriched uranium
to but do you know do you think it
matters whether I think it matters
whether the role I don't know what their
intentions were I don't know if they
knew immediately like okay innocence of
Muslims was not really the problem but
let's find something to blame it on yeah
regardless of what their intentions were
they the media has used innocence of
Muslims or you know Obama using
innocence of Muslims as a way to
criticize him as a way to spin it and
make it seem like he found a cheap skate
scapegoat so that's an issue I think as
soon as it was clear that the CIA or
that the Obama administration had a lack
of intelligence they should have come
forward and said look there was an issue
we're being honest with the public but
there's always a lack of answers you
can't do it because you can't be a
decent honest human being in this
climate because anyway they're like
wolves now the other side they'll just
tear his throat out if he shows a bit of
that kind of honesty you can also
be you can also be honest and just say
like look with the CIA doesn't have like
superpowers you know there are gonna be
flaws and intelligence and you can't
have nobody wants to hear right that's
unfortunate right we all want that
intellectual everybody wants to be made
safe I know they think they're being
made safe do you know why there hasn't
been an attack as no-one's planned one
yet
you know maybe they've warded some
things but you cannot be made safe you
have to know that life goes on and there
are open holes for crazy people I
actually have a question because I'm
very curious to see what you think so
that there are rumors that the reason
why the write is really holding on to
this issue is because in 2016 you know
the Republicans want to use this as a
way to attack Hillary are they gonna
talk about it for three more years
wondering is that a legitimate thing to
say well it seemed obvious to me that
their use they're gonna hold this thing
so that if the fall goes on Hillary and
even today you could see people were
already saying is Obama now gonna have
to throw Hillary under the bus as this
thing keeps getting bigger so it's
ridiculous if you let biet let them
determine that right but the point is
they have to it's like planting a tree
and they have to plant it so deep right
now that is flowers and three years when
they refer back to it they have to plan
and what they've learned from the Bush
administration is the way Bush and
Cheney got away with everything if you
look at their speeches the words 9/11
were a thousand times a week you know
it's not ten thousand times a week later
yes if you repeat and you repeat and you
repeat and then that's what it is so
they're planting the Benghazi seeds for
later but there's nothing there yeah but
all right so as a obviously someone on
the more progressive situs does do you
fear that if the progressives become as
bad using the use those same evil
tactics are we losing something in the
process of that well have we used the
same evil tactics you mean because he
lied he lied about yeah he tried to
change yeah if the other side uses the
bad tactics too like what are we losing
in the course of that we like to see
anybody loot no I'm not willing to do
anything but if he made a mistake he
made a mistake the deaths had occurred
already if he gave the wrong story in a
bad story or he lied okay his lying did
not cause more deaths and he didn't lie
to the point where he could continue to
kill the way Bush
Shanee did in all these wars he you know
it's wrong he should you know man up and
move forward and not do it he should man
up I think the way that it played out it
made it seem like Obama was refusing to
admit the failures of his own
administration right and looking for a
cop-out so that made him I in a lot of
ways that made him look weak yeah I
agree there's nothing weird about that
we view the president in a way that he
should know everything at all times why
don't you know even but the IRS thing
why do we think that some low-level
employees now they're saying low-level
and it may have gotten a little higher
but that a bunch of guys in Cincinnati
we're doing something we think well the
president should know about that we
think the president should know about
the security at the elevator in Benghazi
we think that this guy should basically
be God which you know unfair
expectations of the President of the
United States but on the other hand he's
the president of the United States you
know what I mean gonna get it nothing
you're just gonna get it you know of
course you're a human you're gonna have
flaws that's totally understandable but
at the same time when it comes to big
issues like this you should be briefed
you should know what's going on on the
other hand because people do think you
should know every single thing and I
really think this country has in the
last few decades just embrace such a
lack of responsibility and there is this
daddy issue in this country everybody
wants this daddy to take care of
everything you know keep us safe what do
people do to keep themselves safe they
complain every time they have to take
their shoes off there's so little
responsibility and so much counting on
someone taking care of you that they're
just appalled or frightened when there's
a little break in the power yeah that's
really interesting this up something
I've been thinking about lately that
maybe in America we need what they have
in most of Europe which is a prime
minister who really serves as what our
president is the guy doing policy and
then have a president that's more in
line with something you know ceremonial
because I feel like we get all our
ceremonial stuff out with Obama but
maybe we need really like some hardcore
prick to be the president and he's not a
hardcore prick but we love him dancing
with Beyonce and all that stuff you
wanted to dance with them
maybe we emphasize the role of the
vice-president I mean the vice-president
was like the most we tried that last
time maybe the public gets a vote on who
the Vice President is as well as opposed
to having lady do it I think I think
that once the president selected that
has to be the vice president from the
other party and then Congress has to
work with the to it well that's how to
win I like that I like it to hurt here
first people Elayne Boosler changing the
face of the nation yeah good luck with
that maybe you'll run how about that oh
no I well we've had several right and I
think the amount of times I've used
certain words on my Facebook page we
just eliminate me from being able to run
exactly sure love cursing and writing
Lenovo's is the official outfitter of
the Rubin report I want to put you in
this shirt go to bonobos calm enter code
TR are 2-0 for 20% off your first
purchase